I'm sure a lot of people made
resolutions for the new year I know I
did I know some of you did and I know
how hard it is to stick with new year's
resolutions so right now I thought I'd
check in with our studio audience see
how they're doing with their own
personal New Year's resolutions let's
check out our yeah this would be funny
we're not close free let's check out our
first audience members new year's
resolution let's check it out here's his
resolution finally defeat Liam Neeson in
taken four
look at this one open an Etsy shop it
sells jewelry made from stolen
windchimes
[Music]
beautiful inventive this one to invent a
cool new verb Skiz then just you know
Skiz it up all year long here's one look
at this be the James Dean of Reseda
[Applause]
[Music]
and then there's this guy find out what
scuse me
[Music]
for this one update resume to include
treasurer sublime fanclub
here's one open up a CrossFit across
from my current CrossFit I'll call it a
CrossFit
and finally tell mom to stop dressing us
alone
they're where cars rather low tank
you